this video is sponsored by squarespace
huge thanks to those guys for supporting
the channel
we can argue all day about what the most
functional exercises are but i think
that undoubtedly the most fundamental
human movements have to be walking and
running it's what we do the most of in
our daily lives is what the body is
designed to do there are so many huge
benefits to running and it goes far
beyond cardio and just losing a bit of
weight it's actually a pet peeve of mine
when you hear people saying that if
you're not running a certain amount
there's no point because you're not
going to be running further or lowering
your times that's not all that running
is about if you run just once a week the
benefits can be transformative that's
what we're going to be talking about in
this video
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so of course running is really good for
cardio and burning fat and there's this
big argument as to whether it's as good
as high intensity interval training
however there are very different
benefits to each whilst high intensity
interval training can be really good for
quickly burning calories and the
afterburn effect which we'll talk about
running for long distances liss low
intensity steady state cardio is better
for enlarging your heart it improves
your stroke volume and your qmax your
quantified maximum cardiac
output you know many more benefits we're
gonna see in a minute that increased
heart size and qmax is valuable too this
is what leads to a lower resting heart
rate an important marker of overall
health
imagine receiving more blood and oxygen
to your brain and muscle with every
heartbeat
so many people are looking for a hack or
a trick to quickly gain more energy but
the solution has been there all along
run
on paper hit provides a more efficient
way to burn a similar number of calories
in less time then there's the afterburn
effect that sees the body burn more
calories following a high intensity
workout
but this often gets overstated while the
afterburn effect can increase calorie
burn for around one to two hours
post-exercise studies suggest it's not
enough to make any significant
difference versus a comparable long run
and sure you can burn more calories with
hip more quickly but don't be mistaken
this isn't the easy shortcut it might
sound like hit is called high intensity
for a reason these sessions are brutally
taxing for most people and i personally
find running gently for 50 minutes to be
less grueling and more appealing and you
can easily burn 800 calories or more in
that time that's enough to make a
significant impact on your total calorie
count for the entire week
none of this is to say that hit isn't
useful it has its own merits it's better
for increasing mitochondrial count and
function for example i'm just saying
that you should do both there go
everyone should run
but the real case i'm trying to make
here is that running is about more than
just burning calories and getting better
at running but what's really game
changing when it comes to long distance
running is what it can do for your
biomechanics because it teaches you to
run and move properly we spend so long
sitting in one place that not only do we
get kyphosis tight hip flexors etc we
also forget how to move properly we have
weaker cores because we aren't using
them throughout the day running
encourages us to move properly it
strengthens our hips which can prevent
knee pain it can help to avoid injuring
yourself or falling over you have to
keep your core straight and upright
especially if you're running in barefoot
where more upright posture is encouraged
and this can be really game changing
when it comes to the way you move and
injury prevention
if you sit at a desk for eight hours a
day five days a week then there's only
so much benefit that you can get from
doing three times ten squats just a few
times a week the sitting is by far the
larger stimulus but running is
essentially an extremely high volume
exercise that hip flexor strength is
what will prevent you from dragging your
feet when you reach old age along with
lifting your feet via the anterior
tibialis again for thousands of reps and
now let's take a moment to talk about
today's sponsor squarespace squarespace
is a powerful online platform for
developing modern attractive and
professional websites it gives you all
the tools to easily create your own site
with zero coding necessary this way you
can turn your passion into a business
squarespace makes this easy with a
number of features start generating
revenue through gated members only
content manage members send email
communications and leverage audience
insights all from a single easy to use
platform
you'll be able to build your own
community of like-minded folks thanks to
a fully integrated commenting system
with support for threaded comments
replies and likes with powerful blogging
tools at your disposal you'll be able to
share content categorize posts schedule
publishing and more you can also easily
display posts from your social profiles
directly on your website and push
content from your favorite social
channels automatically
want to sell products from your site
squarespace comes with powerful
ecommerce capabilities that can be
upgraded with additional extensions
these third-party tools let you manage
your inventory promote products
streamline bookkeeping reconcile and
file sales tax and ship items around the
world go to squarespace.com for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
bioneer viewers can get 10 off the
purchase of their first website or
domain by going to squarespace.com
forward slash bioneer today a massive
thanks once again to squarespace and now
on with the show
it's our core strength that really
suffers from our day-to-day inactivity
if you're mindful of your posture when
running you should be keeping an upright
torso especially if you run in minimal
shoes this requires core stability and
great endurance it's this that will keep
your core strong at the end of the day
so you don't put your back out it will
prevent you from slouching when you're
tired and it's crucial for athletes
running well will teach you correct
biomechanics and undo years of sitting
even if you only go once a week
and running can help your performance in
other ways too
in the short term running helps to
deliver oxygen and blood all around the
body this can be a great form of
recovery following a intense workout the
previous day it helps to deliver the
blood nutrients to the muscles that need
them at the same time though the
long-term benefits for your circulation
are truly amazing so recent research
suggests that training for and running a
single marathon can undo up to four
years worth of arterial aging more to
the point through a process called
angiogenesis you actually create new
blood vessels and increase blood supply
to every part of the body that means
more blood and oxygen to the muscles
when you're training therefore improving
your performance plus more blood and
oxygen and nutrients to the muscles when
you're recovering therefore helping you
to increase hypertrophy and recover
faster and there are even studies
suggesting that increased blood supply
to a muscle can increase your myonucleic
count that means more protein synthesis
and it means permanently more protein
synthesis because my nuclei stick around
as far as we know indefinitely then
there's the bone mass running
strengthens the bones and therefore
reduces the likelihood of fractures and
other injuries
the thing is this doesn't have to be
fast in fact many of these benefits will
be more pronounced if you run gently
keep moving and supply the body with
more blood and nutrients while you let
your mind unwind and as an added bonus
this is also much easier to be
consistent with
and when you hear about tribes of
long-distance runners like the
tarahumara it's useful to note that they
run gently too and if you can't run at
all for whatever reason gentle walking
will offer many of these same similar
benefits
this is also how you prevent many of the
negative effects associated with running
gentle running provides a lower amount
of impact you can mitigate unwanted side
effects further by running in minimal
footwear and getting off the beaten path
issues like tight i.t bands are the
result of running only in straight lines
and on flat surfaces trail running and
cutting around trees will ensure you're
moving in all planes of motion and
developing a much more rounded and
balanced physique it's about variety
so if you wear barefoot shoes like one
of these
then there's a few things that happen
differently first of all there's no heel
to toe drop this forces you to
land with the ball of the foot more or
the mid foot as you're running this
places the the foot under the center of
the gravity and it allows your knee to
bend properly to absorb the impact
making it less jarring even when you're
running for a long distance at the same
time the fact that it's much easier to
feel the ground underneath you gives you
more proprioceptive feedback so you can
avoid twisting your ankle because you
can feel what's on the ground underneath
you this also makes running a much more
sensory rich and stimulating process at
the same time the wider toe box and the
malleability of the shoe try not to
touch it too much because it's really
muddy
means that your foot can actually
contour to the ground underneath you so
if your foot your toes were to land into
a little hole for example they would
splay out and widen and bend to fit into
that hole of course running outside also
means you get all the benefits that come
from being outside such as the sunlight
exposure for increased vitamin d
stronger bones etc and the ground is
softer although it's not as straight and
flat the fact that it's a bit softer
thanks to mud or grass means it'll
absorb the impact slightly and that
makes it easier on the knees and joints
as well
these are just some of the reasons that
i've worn exclusively barefoot shoes for
the last three years just be sure to
ease into it gently
gentle running also has countless
cognitive benefits we all know that
exercise can improve memory and brain
plasticity but most studies suggest that
cardio is the most effective in this
regard likely due to the increased blood
flow
you're literally rooting more power to
the brain
running also stimulates the release of
endorphins creating the runner's high
and improving general mood
and fans of dr andrew hubermann may have
heard him talk about something called
optic flow basically this is a process
through which your brain needs to
calculate what's going on when it gets
all that visual information as you walk
or run so as it sees objects flying past
your field of view it needs to work out
whether they're moving whether you're
moving or whether both are moving you
need to work out how fast you're going
and all of this can kind of hack the
brain into a state of calm it's like a
form of forced meditation and this has
even shown promise in some studies in
treating people with ptsd so this is a
great way if you struggle to get into a
calm zen like state with regular
meditation to kind of hack that process
and get yourself nice and calm
there's the well-documented notion that
running in particular can encourage the
release of endorphins such as serotonin
the feel-good hormone we don't know
exactly why this is possible it's to do
with all of that extra blood flow to the
brain but the bottom line is it puts you
in the sense of in a state of calm and
good mood so it's a brilliant way to
just de-stress especially after a tough
week and root finding is brilliant for
brain plasticity just ask a taxi driver
here's all you really need to know both
bruce lee and jackie chan ran every
single day during their primes
enough said right as you can see there
are tons of reasons to run every single
week and you don't have to worry about
getting it better at running if that's
not your goal or even losing weight this
is just an all-round great thing to do
for your health you can take it nice and
slow if you fancy useful interesting
guys if you did then please leave a like
and share around that helps me out
immensely subscribe if you want more
like this and be sure to check out super
functional training my e-book training
program in the description down below if
you're interested in improving your
all-round health and performance
thanks for watching this one guys and
i'll see you next time
bye for now
[Music]
what's happening to this guy